Fushiguro isn't sasuke.
Okay, with that out of the way, Quick question
for you: what exactly happened between this
scene here, at the beginning of the story
- and this scene here at the end of the anime's
first season? - the two sequences mirror each
other pretty closely.
Both times the three first years are sent
to investigate a seemingly average case without
the support of any other jujutsu sorcerer,
both times nobora gets taken from the room
and both times it turns out that the curse
they are facing is actually a special grade
that has consumed one of sukunas fingers.
And yet everything is different.
first of all all three of them, voluntarily
enter the curses domain instead of suddenly
being trapped in it.
This time it is Itadori that goes after nobora,
both of them have grown stronger and together
they take out the two special grades in a
very impressive manner.
These two missions are clearly set up to show
the growth of our protagonists here.
And while especially itadoris difference in
power and mentality is clearly visible, the
most drastic character development in this
scene is without any doubt that of Fushiguro,
who doesn't run away like last time, but stands
his ground, lets loose and ultimately defeats
the very same special grade that had seemed
unbeatable just a few weeks earlier, all with
a maniac grin on his face.
So, what happened here?
Who is Megumi?
Why does his role as the typical rival slash
deuteragonist to Itadori work so much better
than in many other stories?
And why is he so important to both sukuna
and gojo?
This is the story of Megumi Fushiguro.
On the surface, Fushiguro seems to be your
typical rival character.
While Itadori appears to have a light mood,
is extremely extroverted and runs mostly on
emotions and instinct, Megumi seems to be
the classic contrast to that.
With dark spiky hair, a quiet and calculating
personality, and having gown up an orphan
due to the harsh clan system of the jujutsu
world, he seems to be the classic trope of
the cool and brooding rival.
the introversion to itadoris extroversion.
The dark to itadoris light.
Fushigoru isn't sasuke.
Because, just as Itadori subverts trope after
trope of your typical shouen protagonist,
fushiguro is nothing like sasuke or bakugo.
His character actually comes a lot closer
to some of Togashi's characters like Kurapika
or Hiei from YuYu Hakusho.
But as always, Akutami has taken a number
of successful character tropes, merged them
and made a character that is much more complex
and intriguing than the sum of its parts.
As you might already have realized without
some dude analyzing anime on the internet
telling you so, the central theme of fushiguro's
character is that of the shadow.
As we will discuss in a second, this of course
goes for his personality and character arc,
but it also directly reflects in his actual
jujutsu abilities.
Megumi is a user of the Ten Shadow Technique,
a rare ability inherited by the powerful Zenin
family, that allows him to control up to ten
Shikinami, a type of spirit, that can be tamed
and used by a sorcerer.
The real feat of his technique however are
not necessarily the Shikinami himself, though
they are his main source of power, but the
fact that Megumi is able to use shadows as
a medium.
He is able to summon his creatures directly
from shadows and is even capable of storing
objects or even himself within them.
We actually see him figure this feature of
his technique out in real time in this scene
here. - and
this is not the only time that its sukuna
who inspires him to get stronger.
I think it's clear that sukuna is not interested
in Megumi for his Shikinami, but for the powers
of his shadows, and so I am sure we will see
fushiguro discover new features and applications
of this ability in the future.
On top of all this, instead of being too cool
and calculating for getting his hands dirty,
Megumi actually likes to fight in close combat
together with his shikigami, something else
that gets him respect from Sukuna, as these
sorts of powers are usually used at range
in the jujutsu world.
But unlike his jujutsu where fushiguro is
able to control shadows, in terms of his character,
he carries a deep darkness within himself
that controls him.
And this Shows in a number of ways.
One of the first things that immeadietly become
clear when we meet fushiguro, is that just
like Itadori, he has a weird tendency for
self-sacrifice.
we know that fushiguro has a trump card up
his sleeve that even was a threat to sukuna,
however that card would come at the cost of
fushiguros own life.
And yet the number of times we see him almost
using this last resort in the first season
of the manga alone is absolutely ridiculous.
Pretty much every enemy that manages to get
fushiguro in a bit of a tight spot, he considers
a worthy target to blow himself up with. and
this fact highlight two other negative traits
of his quite well.
The first is, that he lacks self esteem and
is extremely insecure about his own abilities.
While both gojo and sukuna clearly know that
Megumi is capable of so much more, we are
talking special grade jujutsu here, Megumi
himself, whenever he is challenged, tends
to just give himself up for the rest.
this makes him different from Yuji, who also
likes to sacrifice himself, but only as a
last resort, after having thrown in everything,
having lost limbs and riddled with wounds.
that is actually the entire point of the baseball
match against the Kyoto students.
The secenes where gojo comments on him and
itadori going for the homerun and Megumi sacrificing
himself for the team, are pretty straightforward
metaphors for their general mindset.
The second thing megumis kamikaze attempts
lay open however, go even a bit deeper.
Not only does he not believe in himself, he
has absolutely no sense of self worth.
The underlying reason for this this, is fushiguro's
childhood.
When he and his step sister were abandoned
by his father, leaving both of them orphans,
it left a deep scar on his heart.
As a result, and frankly quite understandably,
he has developed severe abandonment issues,
that make him very cautious about forming
new relationships.
And yet, once these relationships are formed,
he would do anything for the people he holds
dear.
Gojo plays a very interesting role here.
While we know that he technically took Megumi
in and saved him from being sold to the Zenin
family, it doesn't seem like he ever played
the role of a parent for fushiguro.
The relationship between them is much deeper
than that of teacher and student, but not
deep enough to call it family, at least as
far as we know.
And as we see from the small flashback we
get, Gojo, especially in his younger years
was terrible with people.
Gojo didn’t really adopt Megumi, he scouted
him as a future potential student.
He helped him because he saw that potential
in him to become one of the strong allies
in the future.
His apparent lack of empathy probably just
enforced megumis sene of being worthless.
Which is tragic, because Gojo clearly cares
for Megumi, but was never able to show it
in a way that gave Megumi self esteem.
Instead gojo tries to push Megumi to get better
with the only thing he knows, strength.
And so, even though it was a big step for
gojo's character to take him in, it was not
the best one for Megumi.
Interestingly enough however, this has manifested
in probably the best case scenario for Fushiguro.
Instead of hating and blaming everyone for
his childhood like sasuke or trying to proof
himself or get attention from others, he has
developed a truly selfless desire to save
and help those who in his eyes deserve it.
Even at the cost of his own life.
In an ironic twist then, while Itadori tries
to be the ultimate selfless person for selfish
reasons, you can check my analysis on him
for more on that, fushiguro due to his lack
of self-worth simply wants to be useful to
others and thus is the truly altruistic one
of the two.
-
This unique dynamic becomes pretty clear in
his encounter with Kamo during the exchange
event.
Kamo claims that both of them are the same.
And on the surface that may actually be true.
They are both dark haired, quiet, introverts.
They were both born outsiders.
Their parents were both people that the clan
looked down on.
The Zenin and Kamo family respectively only
willing To take them in because they were
born with a strong cursed technique.
They’re both strategists, who act like they’re
logical, but tend to be swayed by emotions
instead.
They’re both trying to protect someone,
Megumi his sister, and Kamo his mother and
both only became jujutsu sorcerers to protect
these people.
So why does Megumi reject this statement by
Kamo so strictly.
After all the poor guy simply wants to be
understood.
The reason here is a moral one, that gives
us a lot of insight into Fushiguros character.
Kamo basically argues, that as members of
the big clans, they are expected to think
in terms of what is best for the family and
society as a whole.
there is no room to view itadori from a personal
perspective.
Sukuna is a threat and thus itadori must be
eliminated for the good of all.
kamo uses this utilitarian argument and his
duty to his family to justify a morally questionable
decision that he personally does not agree
with.
To find acceptance within the family and within
the jujutsu world, the rules must be obeyed.
Fushiguro however, despite on the surface
also appearing to be someone who acts rationally
and values rules and laws, actually is a lot
more like his teacher and evaluates decision
of his personal impression and gut feeling.
We see this play out pretty nicely in the
very first two episodes, where Megumi even
cites the official jujutsu regulations, threatening
to exorcise itadori.
And yet he had already decided all along,
that he wanted to let him live, based on his
personal feelings.
And yet, while Kamo's morality is very faulty
at best, Megumi's is based on a wrong assumption
just the same.
Similarly to Gon in hunter x hunter, fushiguro
has a very simplified view of human morality.
He unconsciously divides people into either
good or bad, black or white, worth saving
or not worth saving, all based on his personal
impression of them.
Itadori and his sister are good people no
matter what they do.
The prisoner Yuji wanted to save, was a bad
guy.
And it's not really hard to see, why he thinks
that way.
He's a teenager, that was abandoned by both
parents, doesn’t really know how to survive
in the world but he has to pretend that he
does because no one else is there to take
care of him.
Add onto that the fact that he was sort of
forced into becoming a jujutsu sorcerer first
by his dad selling him, then by Gojo only
intervening on the premise that he come to
work with him instead.
Plus, his inability to help his sister in
her condition.
And since he actually is an incredibly kind
and caring person at heart, this simplified
way of looking at people helps him protect
himself from people leaving him again.
As a result, he tells Itadori, that he might
end up saving people who will kill someone
in the future.
The irony of course is that this goes for
fushiguro himself as well.
Saving Itadori has definitely lead to more
death and suffering and the same might be
true for other people he sees as good as well.
He and Yuji actually have a very similar approach
to the question, what does it mean to live
a good life worth living.
Both think the answer is saving people.
However, while Yuji thinks about this in terms
of quantity, saving as many people as possible,
Fushiguro looks at it in terms of quality,
who do I thin is worth saving.
And yet, despite this difference in perspective
and despite the apparent Naruto-sasuke dynamic
between them, the relationship between itadori
and fushiguro is not only a major twist on
the shonen trope, but actually the most postive
aspect of the story.
Megumi and Yuji aren't rivals, they are partners.
They support each other and keep the other
from falling apart under their respective
darkness.
Yes, they have contrasting personalities,
and still they are the closest to each other
and understand each other the best, mostly
because they have the same fixation on saving
people.
The only argument between them is right at
the start of the story, due to their different
ideas on saving people but then never again.
And even then, they respect each others moral
views.
After itadoris death he even hands the prisoners
name tag to his mother, to honor his friends
legacy.
They push each other to grow, without ever
seeing the other person as a threat.
And in direct contrast to the sasukes and
bakugos of the world, instead of refusing
to acknowledge his partner, Fushiguro is the
one that always readily gives validation to
Itadori and defends him.
Protecting the other is always a major drive
for both of them alike, whenever they are
together.
The contrast between them, is a sort of ying
and yang, as both of them complete each other
and are pretty much two sides of the same
coin.
In a way their relationship is represented
really nicely, by fushiguros black and white
wolf.
Just like Yuji, the white wolf dies during
the cursed womb arc.
And yet, it's powers and strengths merge with
the black wolf, making him stronger overall.
And similarly, Yuji and Megumi increasingly
take on traits from each other as the story
progresses.
At the beginning, Megumi is cold, dispassionate,
and entirely selective with his sympathies.
Yuji in contrast is warm, friendly, and willing
to sympathize with almost anybody.
And yet over time, Megumi takes on more of
Yujis emotional, confident and extroverted
self, while Itadori gets a grip on his emotions,
becomes more calculating and is able to make
harder decisions.
In a world that has mostly provided nothing
but pain and hardship for them, both make
each other better and stronger people.
And this brings us aaaall the way back to
the initial question.
What happened between these two scenes with
the special curses.
The answer is: Fushiguro has become amore
like Itadori, and finally has the capability
to not only believe in himself, but also be
more emotional and let them become a strength,
- Todo - or as Megumi puts it very thematically
fitting, finally being able to spit out his
shadow.
This unusual rival relationship is one of
the main reasons why jujutsu Kaiser works,
and why it feels so unique and yet familiar
compared to other shounen stories.
Another really important relationship is that
between Yuji and and the sorcerer who's appeal
is maybe only topped by Gojo's.
So I suggest you watch Nanami's video right
here.
Thanks for watching.
Peace!